GRADY POWELL: Eric, Dave.
Congratulations, gentlemen.
You guys have solidified
yourselves spots
in our third and final
round of this competition.
Now, in this final round, we're
gonna be sending you guys back
to your home forges to build
yet another iconic weapon
from Korean history.
We're gonna have
you build this--
the woldo.
DOUG MARCAIDA: The woldo
is a pole-arm weapon
that has been wielded
by Korean warriors
since the sixth century.
The large crescent
blade provided the user
with incredible force to deliver
lethal blows and deep cuts
with one swing into an opponent.
Historically, this heavy
weapon required special skills
and was only wielded in battle
by elite Korean warriors.
Today, Korean martial artists
who specialize in the woldo
perform intricate maneuvers
with this intimidating weapon at
festivals and cultural events.
All right, gentlemen.
We're giving you four days
to build your woldo swords.
And I want to see your best
work, because one of them
will be worth $10,000.
We'll see you in four days.
[music playing]
ERIC HEMKER: My name is Eric
Hemker, I'm 29 years old,
and I'm a design engineer.
I design seat
structures for cars.
And it's very important,
because if that person's not
comfortable, they're
not gonna buy that car.
Same thing goes for a knife.
If that is not
comfortable, they're
not gonna wield that knife.
There we go.
The woldo is in good shape.
I've got plenty of meat on there
that I can grind back and get
to the shape I'm looking for.
[music playing]
That is a hard blade.
Overall, good clinch.
So I decided, as a little
decorative embellishment,
to add a little
grip to the handle.
I'm gonna flute and
inlay some paracord.
I'm using imperial red
and royal blue to honor
the colors of the Korean flag.
So I'm pleased.
DAVE ARMOUR: My
name is Dave Armour
and I am from Auburn, Illinois.
I got into bladesmithing
when I was 15.
I went to a theme park where
they had a gun and knife shop,
and a man was demonstrating
how to make a knife.
Being 15 and just
being fascinated,
I followed him into his shop
and asked so many questions,
he literally took a book on
knife making that was for sale,
threw it at me, and said,
get the hell out of the shop.
I may have ruined this early on.
I forged a piece over
so that, actually,
the top part was actually
folding over on itself.
It's called a cold shut.
Causes all kinds of
problems later on, 'cause
the pieces aren't attached.
I go over to the grinder.
If I can grind out,
I'm not too bad.
[exhales]
So right now, it's just
back to the grinder.
Good news is,
everything's solid.
The cold shut I was worried
about is grinding out.
I have a blade
ready to heat treat.
Hup.
I'm straight.
[scraping]
Yup.
And it's hard.
That's as good as I
can hope for right now.
So I grabbed some pink paracord
that I'm gonna use to wrap
the areas between the collars.
And then I have a pink
wood stain that I'm going
to stay in the hickory with.
When I do a knife show, I always
have one knife on my table
that has a pink handle.
It's not the
typical-looking thing,
but I think it looks kind of
neat so I'm gonna go with it.
I think this is a solid piece.
I think it'll test well, but
we're gonna see what happens.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths--
--and welcome to the KEAL test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapons will do,
I will take your weapons
and deliver lethal blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Eric, you're first.
You ready for this?
- Yes, sir.
- Right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
[splatting]
All right, Eric.
Let's talk about
your woldo here.
It is forward-heavy.
There's a lot of metal in
here, but it is wieldable.
Now, your edge is sharp.
It penetrates deeply into
this ballistics dummy,
cutting the gel torso
and into the bones.
Over all, sir, your
woldo, it will KEAL.
Thank you.
All right, Dave.
Your turn, sir.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
[splatting]
[thump]
[laughs]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Dave.
Let's talk about
your woldo here.
It is a little bit heavier
than the other weapon.
Heavier weapons require
a lot of adjustments.
But your edge here is sharp
with this forward weight
that cuts deep into
this ballistics dummy
and cuts the bones inside.
But in doing so, sir,
your edge over here
did take a little
bit of rolling.
But the other parts are fine.
And overall, sir,
your woldo will KEAL.
Thank you.
DAVE BAKER: All
right, gentlemen.
You know what time it is.
It's time for the strength test.
We're calling this one
the Bamboo Man Attack.
To test the overall
construction of your blade,
I'm going to take them
and gently tap them
against our bamboo
men over here.
[laughter]
Now, remember, this is not
about what your weapons
do to these targets.
It's about what these
targets do to your weapons.
Eric, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
All right.
[grunts]
[music playing]
[grunting]
[laughs]
DAVE BAKER: So Eric, right
off, this is a heavy beast.
Your balance point's not bad.
I kind of like that
right there where
you can manipulate the weapon.
As far as the weapon
performance goes,
you maintain an edge
all the way along.
It's still sharp.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
All right, Dave.
You're up.
Ready?
- Yes, sir.
[music playing]
[grunting]
All right, Dave.
Your weapon is
really, really heavy.
So you can make a
devastating cut,
but recovery is really slow.
As far as the blade, the blade
itself is dented sideways
here and up above here.
But still solid, so you
survived quite nicely.
Well done, Dave.
Thank you.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths,
this is the sharpness
test, the Sugar Cane Slice.
To find out how sharp
your weapons are,
I'm gonna attempt to cut
through all these sugar canes.
Unlike the strength test,
this is all about what
your weapons do and how well
they cut the sugar canes.
Eric, are you ready to do this?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
[crash]
[thumps]
All right, Eric.
Let's talk about your edge here.
Your edge, it's sharp.
It cut through all
the sugar canes.
And overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thank you.
Dave, it's your turn, sir.
Are you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
[crash]
(QUIETLY) Damn.
All right, Dave.
Let's talk about
your weapon here.
It's still sharp and it cuts
cleanly all the way through.
But the weight of your blade,
as I'm cutting, dragged downward
and I ran out of sugar cane.
But overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thank you.
GRADY POWELL: Well,
gentlemen, you
both performed extremely well
in our Korean theme challenge.
Both your woldos did
great during our tests.
But this is a competition
and there has to be a winner.
The judges have made
the decision and today's
"Forged in Fire" champion is--
Eric.
Congratulations.
Now, Dave, you fought hard.
But unfortunately, you're
not today's winner,
and Dave is gonna tell you why.
DAVE BAKER: Dave, your blade
did great in the KEAL test
and did well in
the sharpness test.
What this came down
to are two things.
The overall weight of
your blade and the damage
it took in the strength test.
Those are the reasons
we're letting you go.
I understand.
Thanks for having me.
GRADY POWELL: Well,
Dave, it's clear you have
what it takes to
fight in this forge.
You're an extremely
talented smith.
But unfortunately, your time
in this competition has ended.
And for that reason, I'm gonna
have to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
(WHISPERING) Good job, man.
Well, Eric, you
know what that means.
You are the newest
"Forged in Fire" champion.
You're gonna be walking out of
here with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
[applause]
ERIC HEMKER: I feel
awesome, coming
out here, winning the
competition, having my skills
validated.
This is a crowning
achievement of mine.
Well done.
Thank you.
If somebody wants
me to make a woldo,
it's gonna cost 'em $10,000.